how's it going everybody it's Warren and
welcome to this week's episode of Theory
Thursdays my weekly segment where you
all submit your theories I choose five
to go over each week you choose which
one you thought was your favorite for
the week and then which one you thought
was your favorite for the month still
giving away two imax tickets right now
to the monthly winner so you can go see
Avengers in Game and IMAX or spider-man
far from home when it comes out if you
would like to submit your own theory for
a chance to end up in Theory Thursdays
you can find the email to send it to in
the description down below
alright so let's dive into this week's
theories our first theory comes from
harsh Grover with a theory on how the
MCU will connect together after the
events of Avengers in game Hirsch says
concerning the new development involving
the multiverse i theorize that each
separate universe out of the infinite
universes in the multiverse have their
own separate set of timelines and
dimensions like the mirror dark and
quantum realm will be used to travel
between the universes proof of this is
that Kevin Feige hinted that the quantum
realm will play a huge role in phase 4
and is likely related to the multiverse
since far from home is the last movie in
phase 3 and will hint at this throughout
the movie and in the post-credits scene
in an interview Tom Holland accidentally
lets slip that Benedict Cumberbatch's
Doctor Strange had a lot of quantum
realm elated lines an in-game but it
didn't really happen I think it's
possible that since Marvel wanted a
really amazing closure to the Avengers
they chose not to include much about
phase 4 because it would distract the
audience from the main event however
they might choose to include references
to this and far from home and in the
post credit scene apart from home has a
good passage into phase 4 it's likely
that Doctor Strange will play a big part
with this in phase 4 because of this
reference and because it's his job to
deal with the outside threats so this
theory has a lot of merits because now
that the multiverse is being introduced
we're obviously going to see characters
go back and forth between universes
which means at some point in time we're
going to see people figure out how to do
that and since the Avengers have already
figured out how to use the quantum realm
to time-travel what makes sense that
they would use the quantum realm to
travel between universes and I've doubt
we've seen the last of the Dark
Dimension in Doctor Strange in fact
Doctor Strange probably already has the
ability to travel between different
universes as it is so perhaps he could
be the key figure to travelling between
the universes in phase 4 of the MCU
so that's theory
one on to number two theory number two
comes from youtube user Mysterio won 2-6
four and they have a theory on Mysterio
this theory states that the ancient one
actually taught Quinton back in a very
special way of the mystical arts a way
that only a few students that trained
under the ancient one knew of I think
that Beck took the power out of hand
killed the others that knew of the power
and left kamar Tosh this is why Beck's
powers look very similar to dr.
Strange's but are still very different I
think that Beck used this power to
travel to a different earth to become
their hero figure like Iron Man but soon
the people of that new earth found out
who he really was
a villain so when the snap happened he
took advantage of it crossed over to our
earth again after hearing about the
death of the ancient one and claimed
that the snap tore a hole in his
dimension I think that at about
three-quarters into the movie Doctor
Strange will tell Peter Beck's true
origin as Beck's betrayal being told
through the generations of the sorcerers
and will help Peter defeat Beck with the
help of shield and then I think the end
credits will be the MCU setting up Kang
the Conqueror as the next villain the
theory that Mysterio was actually taught
by the ancient one is a good theory that
has been going around and their powers
do look very similar however the twist
on this theory is that Quentin Beck was
actually taught some ancient power that
not a lot of people were taught and then
he killed everybody else that knew it
besides the ancient one and then he used
that power to go to a different universe
so this theory is that the snap tearing
a hole through Earth's dimension is fake
but the multiverse is still real which I
do like the idea of and if this is the
case then Doctor Strange would
definitely know who Quentin Beck is so
it would make sense that he would tell
spider-man about his origin and help him
defeat him so that does it for theory
number two on to theory number three
theory number three comes from Xander
Petawawa the theory about Captain
America and how he got his superpowers
and this theory correlates with black
panther Xander says what if Captain
America Super Soldier Serum wasn't
actually made from technology but is
actually made using the heart-shaped
herb I think that the American
government had some sort of contact with
Wakanda and made some sort of deal a
deal to get a heart-shaped herb and some
vibranium if you remember the American
government tried previously to make a
super soldier but that didn't turn out
well I think that they first tried to
make a Super Soldier Serum with
technology but failed and then used the
heart-shaped herb that they got
Khanda this theory actually makes a lot
of sense because if you look at Captain
America's Civil War and you look at
Avengers infinity war and Avengers in
game there are a lot of similarities
between Black Panther and Captain
America they tend to be the same speed
they tend to move the same way and their
body builds are kind of the same as well
and they did try to build super soldiers
before and it didn't work perhaps why it
worked on Captain America is because of
the heart-shaped
herb and clearly the government had some
sort of contact with Wakanda or somebody
who has been to Wakanda because they did
have vibranium which is what cap shield
is made out of so you never know maybe
Captain America got his powers from the
heart-shaped herb so that's it for
theory number three on to theory number
four theory number four comes from
Mansell Jennings with another Captain
America theory that ties into the x-men
being introduced into the MCU Mansell's
theory states that since Captain
America's kids have the Super Soldier
DNA they would have some sort of
superhuman strength this could allow
Charles Xavier to have interest and
invite them to a school for gifted
youngsters this would allow the x-men to
be introduced with gene mutation like
how Christopher Markus and Stephen
McFeely had said the word would
eventually get out about the school and
Nick Fury would be interested in the
gifted youngsters Nick Fury would go
there and want to recruit some of the
mutants Charles would say no and would
tell him to leave but would eventually
think about making the x-men team to
help the world through a major crisis
this could start a disagreement within
the mutants in the school and around the
world some would want to have a team and
others would want to stay in the shadows
this could introduce many bad mutants
into the MCU as well such as Dark
Phoenix and others so this theory ties
into what Avengers endgame writers
Christopher Markus and Stephen McFeely
said about Captain America's kids having
the super soldier DNA they did confirm
that this is true so this lines right up
with that and it would be really cool to
have Captain America's kids enter the
MCU because if they're anything like
their father they're not going to be
able to sit back while all this bad
stuff happens in the planet they want to
do something to try and stop all the bad
things that are happening and this way
introducing the X minutes of the MCU is
kind of acting like they've been there
the whole entire time Charles Xavier
already has his school set up and he
recruits Captain America's two kids to
come to the school and this is where
they could introduce all of the other
x-men something that I cannot wait to
happen in the MCU so that's it for
the forth theory on to the final theory
number five theory number five comes
from Jay shadow with the theory that the
Hulk when he snapped actually brought
back the original Infinity stones J
states that there were two snaps before
Hulk snapped the first one that was used
to get rid of half of the population
from the universe and the second was
used to destroy the stones both were
technically used to destroy so if
professor Hulk's snap brought everything
that was destroyed back he could have
brought back the Infinity stones to
their original form so this theory
actually ties into what the directors
Anthony and Joe Russo said about
Avengers in game and the Infinity stones
actually not being completely destroyed
they said that the stones were
technically reduced to atoms just like
faina said in the movie and aren't gone
completely implying that they can be
restored somehow and used again so maybe
when Hulk undid everything that Thanos
did with the stones he brought back the
stones
since Thanos did destroy the stones it
certainly would not surprise me if this
were the case because I doubt we've seen
the loss of the Infinity stones in the
MCU and if this is the case they could
definitely introduce infinity watch
which is something that I would love to
see so those are this week's theories
for a theory Thursday let's do a quick
recap theory number one is that the
mirror dimension the Dark Dimension and
that the quantum realm are going to be
used to travel between the universes in
the MCU multiverse theory number two is
that Quinton Beck was actually taught a
rare form of the mystic arts by the
ancient one and then left to a different
universe then after he found out the
ancient one was dead he came back to our
earth and eventually dr. strange tells
Peter Parker who he is and they defeat
him together theory number three is that
the Super Soldier Serum that made
Captain America into who he is was
actually made from the heart-shaped herb
theory number four is that Captain
America's children having the Super
Soldier DNA get invited to Charles
Xavier school and this introduces the
x-men into the MCU and theory number
five is that when the Hulk snapped he
actually brought back the Infinity
stones in their original form so that
does it for this week's theories again
do not forget to vote on which one you
thought was your favorite this week if
you would like to enter your own theory
for a chance to end up an episode of
Theory Thursdays you can find the email
to send it to and the
corrections in the description down
below as always thank you all for
joining me here on Theory Thursdays and
thank you all so much for watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]
you